la dernière clinique d'avortement du
Mississippi a fermé ses portes
mais pas avant une dernière
confrontation
[Musique]
la bataille judiciaire se jouait depuis
des années
ces manifestants anti-avortement et
religieux ont obtenu gain de cause au
grand dam de cette femme
[Musique]
afin de protéger les droits des femmes
qui souhaitent obtenir un avortement
partout aux États-Unis le président
Biden signe un décret qui permettra
entre autres de garantir l'accès à la
pilule abortive et à la contraception
mais la façon la plus rapide dit-il de
rétablir la pratique médicale dans tous
les états et d'adopter une loi fédérale
pour se faire il faudra plus d'élus pro
choix au Congrès
il y a des élections en novembre voter
voter voter dit-il aux Américains le
président s'adresse tout
particulièrement aux femmes des
banlieues l'un des électorales les plus
convoités elles ont fait pencher la
balance plus souvent qu'à leur tour ces
dernières années
dans plusieurs États les Américains
pourront faire élire des gouverneurs
comme celui de la Caroline du Nord qui
veut protéger le droit à l'avortement
votre code postal croit-il ne devrait
pas déterminer
vos droits pourtant cette clinique du
Mississippi aujourd'hui fermé rouvrira
aux nouveaux Mexique où elle pourra
poursuivre ses activités les élections
de mi-mandat cet automne seront donc
déterminantes l'avortement sera sans
doute l'une des questions les plus
importantes pour les électeurs la
bataille judiciaire est peut-être
terminée pour l'instant mais la bataille
politique elle et bel et bien engagée
ici Sébastien Desrosiers Radio-Canada
Washington